hi everyone and welcome
we're glad that you can join us for a
very exciting panel discussion with some
of the industry's leading experts in
forensic science and criminal justice
my name is shireen darwish i'm the north
america market development manager at
thermo fisher scientific
and it's my pleasure to introduce dr
jack valentine
who will be our moderator for this
discussion for a full listing of speaker
bios please click on the tab at the top
of your screen
we encourage you to submit your
questions to our panelists via the q a
box to the left
and we'll try our best to get to as many
questions as possible during the session
as a reminder the hits conference offers
free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing educations credits tab
located in the top right corner of your
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits
and with that please welcome me please
join me in welcoming dr
jack valentine
well good morning good afternoon or good
evening and welcome to everyone
wherever you are in space or time
as you can see i've got a mask i'm in
florida my name is jack valentine
and i'm going to be your moderator for
what should be an interesting and
thought-provoking panel discussion
um that is in accord with the theme of
the meeting
which is partnership in criminal justice
this particular panel is principally
targeted towards an american
time zone thus participants will mainly
be from north south and central america
however i'm sure we will be joined by
other participants across the world
depending upon their interests
and sleeping habits we've already heard
how dna has had an impact on
the criminal justice system this panel
discussion follows on from this and
we'll focus on how we can maximize
that impact so the typical course of
investigation proceeds
as follows a crime occurs which involves
a victim
law enforcement investigates the case
circumstances
a suspect is developed and if sufficient
evidence exists
brought to trial trial by a career
prosecutor
the role of the forensic scientist is
via circumstantial physical evidence to
help establish facts
that may be in question forensic science
providers thus can help with both the
investigative phase
and the dispositive that is the court
phase so
law enforcement prosecutors and forensic
scientists need to work together
as a team if justice is to be said best
served
we cannot forget the victim in all of
this the whole point of prosecuting and
convicting a perpetrator is to provide
justice for the victim
and some sense of closure to the victims
and or their loved ones
these victims often also play a role
during the investigation and prosecution
of crime
indeed in the dna era victims advocates
have played an important role
in persuading the body politic of the
need for legislation to promote the
effective use of dna analysis
so given the necessity for teamwork
we've assembled
a distinguished panel of experts that
includes a law enforcement investigator
a legal expert a victims advocate
and a forensic expert to discuss how to
get the most out of
forensic dna so the format of the
session will be as follows i will ask
each of the panelists in turn
to briefly introduce themselves uh why
they are here
and give their initial thoughts from a
30 000 feet perspective
on what they think is an important thing
they would like to see done
that would help maximize the impact of
forensic dna in the criminal justice
system
once these initial introductions and
personal perspectives have been
completed
we will proceed to discuss in more
detail a number of pre-chosen topics
during the panel session we will take
and encourage general or specifically
address questions from the audience
through the q a function so if any
members of the audience would like to
ask questions please feel free to do so
through the q a function so without
further ado let me introduce the panel
firstly the law enforcement investigator
we have fred haran director of public
safety
from bensalem township pennsylvania fred
thank you jack good
good afternoon good morning as jacket
said where everybody is in the world my
name is fred herron i'm the director of
public safety for bensalem
the tancho police department director of
public safety uh for those of you that
know don't know it's an equivalent to
the police chief so i just want you to
understand what
what that means let me tell you a little
bit real quick about where we are
because i'm sure no one here has heard
of benson township
uh so benson township we border
philadelphia
uh in the u.s right on their northern
border we bought
bordered on multiple fronts the city of
philadelphia which is the fifth largest
city in the united states
unfortunately the good things and bad
things about bordering a big city is it
comes with big city crime and big city
problems as well
and uh philadelphia region the five the
four counties and philadelphia
are the opioid capital of the united
states where there's so much opioid
distribution
uh that it affects many many other
crimes
and what we started to find is that when
we were utilizing the database psychotis
the federal national database it was
really going after
uh homicides and sexual assaults there's
18 000 police departments in the united
states
most of them are like me small
departments i have 106 sworn
in my municipality and my biggest
problems thank god are not homicide and
sexual assault
but they are property crime they are
some robberies but also mainly
burglaries and thefts
and the the codis database was not
something that was really attacking that
so in 2010 we looked at a local database
in collecting our own dna
from suspects and from crime scenes from
every crime scene
and then in 2017 we became the first
police department in the united states
to have a rapid dna instrument
in the police department operating 24 7
by law enforcement officers
and we've taken dna to a whole new
height here we utilize dna every day and
that's our motto it's just not a
it's just not a program it's a
philosophy it's a way of life and
some of the results that we've seen is
we've seen a 42 percent reduction in
burglaries we've seen a 51 percent
reduction in robbery
we've seen uh i think it's about 26
percent reduction in auto theft
so we're seeing some incredible
reductions and
we're utilizing dna every day for every
crime possible
and especially drugs small amounts of
drugs or drug delivery
we're making sure we take dna not just
from the crime scenes and
evidence but also from the people that
we come in contact with and we'll talk
about that more later when we get into
some questions
so thank you and thank you for having me
jack
thanks fred um uh
the next panelist is the legal expert
anne marie schubert who is the elected
sacramento county district attorney
uh anne marie good morning dr valentine
thank you all for having me out here in
california it's nine o'clock in the
morning
um just a little background about myself
i i've been the elected district
attorney in sacramento since 2015 but
i've been
a career prosecutor since 1990. my first
introduction to dna was in the early 90s
my first prosecution involving a serial
rapist and it was the first
hearing that i had to do with the
admissibility of dna and it was at that
time in the mid 90s that i realized that
dna
is the greatest tool ever given to law
enforcement to find the truth no matter
what that truth is and so i've had the
fortune of of working in this field as a
prosecutor for
you know 20 something years um and i've
done i've tried a lot of cases involving
dna
uh realized the value of codis and the
dna databank
and through that time i've also come to
realize that
we have to use dna to the best of our
ability not only to identify
the guilty but to exonerate the innocent
and so many folks probably know that
somewhat of the culmination of of
our use of dna has recently come in the
last couple years with now the
introduction of
what i call investigative genetic
genealogy and many people probably know
that our office the sacramento da's
office and many other da's office have
come
together and are currently prosecuting
the alleged golden state killer
joseph d'angelo for a series of murders
and rapes that occurred here in
california
so i am 100 behind this technology and
i'm just honored to be here dr valentine
so thank you for having me
thank you marie um we have a victim's
advocate
uh jayanne cepage the victims who's a
victims advocate and the founder of dna
saves jayanne thank you dr
hello everyone in 2003 my daughter katie
was a 22 year old graduate
student at new mexico state university
when she was very brutally raped and
murdered
and there was very little evidence in
her case that katie fought
hard for her life and underneath her
fingernail was the skin and blood of the
man that had killed her
and the detective in charge of her case
told me
about the codis system and he explained
to me that a dna profile had been
extracted
from from that blood and skin found
under her fingernails and uploaded into
the national forensic dna database
called codis
and he explained to me that there had
they did not find a match
when they put that in there but once a
week they would be running it again
and look for a match between her crime
scene evidence which was found under her
fingernails
and the offender that might have done
this that would have done this to her if
there's a match
and this gave us bright hope because we
knew we had the identity of katie's
killer we just had to match a name to it
and i made the offhand comment that this
man was such a monster that he would be
arrested again and they would swab his
cheek and we would identify him and
that's when i learned
that at that time in new mexico my home
state and almost every other
it was illegal to take someone's dna
when they were arrested for a crime
so in 2005 our family decided to make it
our mission to change laws all across
the country
so that we could expand the dna database
to include
a profile from those arrested for a
crime
and now 31 states do have a law
that requires that dna be taken as a
result of a felony arrest
and we will continue to try to get every
state to have this law across the
country
it brings justice to families like ours
to victims
it also prevents future crimes which
means it prevents
that horrible agony that families go
through as a result of a crime
so from my perspective the best way that
we can maximize dna
is to expand the database to include
more offenders
more crime scene evidence and i also
believe that rapid dna which is now just
becoming a reality
is a wonderful wonderful tool
to maximize the use of dna so thank you
jack
thank you jan um our forensic expert is
anna titania a forensic scientist in the
uh orange in the science and technology
unit
of the orange county district attorney's
office in california
um so anna
thank you jack as you said i work at the
orange county district attorney's office
which is a little bit different than
most forensic scientists who work in the
crime lab i work actually alongside
prosecutors and investigators and our
mission here in the science of
technology unit
is to truly harness the power of
forensic dna
to not only use it as a prime
solving tool but also use it as a crime
stopping tool
so with that back in 2007 our office
started a local dna database program
it's a consensual database and that was
started
based off of the need to combat property
crime
and then in 2014 we brought on the rapid
dna program
which we've seen tremendous success in
helping not only solve crime but stop it
in its tracks
thank you thank you thank you anna
so let's move on then to um know that we
we have the panel
uh impaneled let's uh discuss some
pre-chosen
topics um the
um let's start with dna databases uh
although we've covered some of this
already but basically
dna databases come in in multiple
flavors
first of all we have the well
established legally supported government
convicted offender or sde databases
which will also include crime scene
samples
this is exemplified of course in the us
by by codis
but most other developed nations have
some such database
and the samples that are input have to
meet rigorous quality assurance
standards
this type of database is used in both in
this positive phase
that is a court phase and the intel the
intelligence phase
of the criminal investigation however
more recently as we've heard
uh other databases uh the sole purpose
of which is for intelligence purposes
and our characteristics the lacking
explicit specific legal authorization
but are nevertheless still legal since
they comprise samples that are
voluntarily provided
examples include the local person of
interest database and crime scene
material
that fred herran just talked about which
are often associated with the use of a
rapid dna program
and genealogical databases that um uh
angry um talked about briefly also
so the first question to the panelists
um would be um how do you currently use
dna data
databases but how do you measure their
impact
so um not just how to use them you may
have discussed that already but also how
do you measure the
impact of these databases so i'm going
to ask anna
to start with that question
thank you jack so here in california
local law enforcement dna databases
are allowed by california law for
identification purposes
so back in 2007 our office decided to
start a database
dna database collection program and it
was decided that it would be based on
the voluntary consent
to provide dna as part of plea deals on
misdemeanors so these cases would not
typically
um be eligible for codis
so um this is offered by the district
attorney's office and the courts
and consent for giving dna is given in
front of
the judge the defense attorney and the
prosecutor
so today we have over 195
000 individuals in our database which is
larger than many even state databases
in the united states and this is
separate and apart from dakota state
which is also in california in addition
our local codas database the orange
county crime lab also sends all their
dna profiles from
crime scene evidence to be searched
against our database so this includes
profiles that are submitted to codis and
also profiles that are not eligible for
quotas
so we have over 13 000 crime scene
profiles in our database
as well so this gives orange county
which has over 3 million people and over
30
law enforcement agencies a huge
additional tool to solve crime
many of these individuals will not be in
the codis databases because these
misdemeanors do not qualify for state
collection
and in addition since we have this local
dna database
we're able to have a successful rapid
dna program
where we can run crime scene evidence
and get dna profiles
and search them against our local dna
babies because
as of now rapid dna profiles are not
allowed to be searched against codis so
the way to really harness that new
technology is with our local dna
database
program so it started with just uh
seeing
um that databases are necessary to
combat
not only and solve higher level crimes
um like murders and race but also with
property crimes so we've seen
a huge success in solving these property
crimes where these individuals would not
be
um in the database and the state
database otherwise
thank you what about the impact do you
measure the impact in quantitatively in
any way
shape or form to help your uh to help
you know improve your program
well so we get depending on the week we
get
you know close to 30 40 50 hits
depending on how many profiles that we
have to search
but the hard part is and we've tried to
qualify uh
quantitative is um like
at what what are you quantifying at what
point um
in the whole investigation or in um
the uh i guess in the filing stage or in
the court process or what part are you
uh quantitating so it's kind of a
difficult thing
um quantitative but we have seen that um
they
our agencies see much more um
many more hits because of this that
these misdemeanors
um these offenders that are committing
the misdemeanors would not have been in
the state database otherwise
and we see these hits and a lot and we
see that also that
these offenders they're reoffending in
the same you know town the same county
um so um being collected here
and having these local offenders in our
database is a huge um
uh help okay thank you um
i should like to remind the audience um
that
please ask questions as we're going
along here through that q a function
or q a's section um fred is there
anything else you'd like to add to that
because i know that you
your agency you have uh spent a lot of
time with the impact side of things with
regard to rapid dna
the success of it within your
jurisdiction
yeah no you know and anna said it uh
said it so uh so well in her opening and
in this last question but
you know the the impact and the real
success is stopping crime in its tracks
so in pennsylvania it was taking 12 to
18 months to get dna
practice in our state lab there's only
one lab
that that deals with all 1200 police
departments with the exception of
philadelphia and pittsburgh police that
have their own labs so
everybody was sending all their dna to
one lab so that that really wasn't
working getting dna results back in 12
to 18 months is not getting results back
so when we started local databasing we
started getting results back in 30 days
and now when we're on board with rapid
we're getting dna back in 90 minutes so
when we have someone in custody for a
crime
and we throw them in the in the through
the rapid machine they hit to our local
database
and they hit to you know two or three
burglaries or some thefts or whatever
other jobs we have open out there
that's getting them off the street and
it's not so much like anna said not so
much about
arresting the criminal but that person
is not on the street at 91 minutes to
commit their next crime and if you are a
victim or
or a possibly potential victim which
you'll never know that you were a
potential victim
because rapid dna took that person off
the street and that criminal
never got an opportunity to victimize
your family
and our results as i said you know 42
reduction in burglary is
some amazing amazing results and i think
it's a 53 percent reduction
in robbery i think i said 51 before i
just checked my stats real quick
so at a 46 reduction in auto theft
um so it's some incredible numbers and
and that's really you know how this
works for us
as jay ann said uh we're one of the 19
that are not a rusty state so i'm a
convicted felon state in pennsylvania
which really does mean no good um like
anna said most of the criminals are
local a lot of them
aren't going to jail for felonies uh in
in these days uh
it's harder even harder to incarcerate
people so
you know getting them off the street and
and getting charges on them
from multiple cases is mostly is more
likely to get them off the street so
they cannot victimize anybody else
at the end of the day what you're doing
in our in the criminal justice whether
you're an analyst you're a d.a
or a victim's advocate or law
enforcement whatever you are
your end of the day goal is to make sure
there's one less victim and
and that's what local databasing and
rapid does
okay thanks fred um coming to anne maria
marie's a prosecutor so she
she uses um databases
in court for sure she'll use the codis
database
i'm not so sure about the uh the
voluntary databases but
do you have any comment and regarding
anne marie sorry
how you currently use these databases
and measure the impact um
any comment about the use the use of
these two types of databases
as a prosecutor i mean i think since
since the
you know the mid 90s the expansion of
these databases
has you know astronomically uh increased
our ability to solve crime so when
jayanne talks about
the importance of of the felony arrestee
provisions that is critical i mean we've
seen
in california we do have that provision
and it was similar to jayann it was led
by bruce harrington who's the
brother of a victim of the golden state
killer but prior to that
law being passed our ability to solve
crime and codis was
was limited but since that time there's
been well over 70
000 cases so you take that that database
and then
in california we now allow familial
searching which has been allowed for
about nine
nine or ten years and then just recently
in the last two years the use of
genealogy databases so
um that is going to astronomically again
increase our ability to solve crime so
our our analysis as a prosecutor is
always the balance of public safety
versus
privacy interests and and there are
privacy interests involved
but for us in in in our case work we're
not actually using the database in court
what we're simply doing is those
databases whether it's codis whether
it's a genealogy site or an
investigative lead
and then we're always going to rely on
our crime labs to go back to traditional
dna testing such as
obviously str so so like a genealogy
site might lead us to a potential
relative
and that then leads us to the suspect
but we're always always going to go back
to traditional dna we're going to use
str's we're going to get a one-to-one
comparison and we're ultimately going to
use that one-to-one comparison so
while codiffs and genealogy sites are
leading us to our suspect
it's ultimately that one-to-one
comparison that
is going to be utilized in a courtroom
okay thank you i think thanks anne-marie
um
so let's let's consider then how do you
overcome any public
and political challenges related to the
expansion
of forensic dna databases because that
the theme seems to be we'd like to
expand
these databases they'll be more useful
so what um
so firstly what role can victim
advocates play in
it's helping expand and implementing dna
database legislation and of course jian
has had quite a bit of experience with
doing that so what role can the victim's
advocates play
gian in in helping expand and
implementing these
the legislation for dna databases jan
thank you jack i think the most
important role that we play is
opening up the conversation and putting
a victim's face
on these conversations and opening up
people's hearts and minds
but it's not enough just to talk about
you know why
why it hurts us why we need to prevent
these crimes we also need to educate and
we need to explain
to these policy makers how these systems
really work
and and how they are not an invasion of
privacy and
and how they actually save the taxpayers
money and
when someone i testify i have a lot of
facts and figures
that back this up studies that have been
done and also
successes you know we can say in my home
state of new mexico we've had over 2 000
matches between crime scene evidence and
those that were arrested for a felony
and how successful we have been and how
those leads have brought convictions
and that so that's really the role that
victims advocates play
is putting a face uh on that law
saying why this is important and also
then education
and showing the exactly how those
systems work
thank you jan um basically
and anne marie did mention this briefly
but
privacy issues is privacy issues an
impediment you think
um or are privacy issues an impediment
to persuading the body politic
to help expand these databases
and marie just do you believe that uh
private issues
are a potential impediment to to to the
these databases i think privacy issues
are real
but they're also something that like
jayanne mentioned if we can educate the
public so for instance one of the
misinformations out there with genealogy
rights is somehow law enforcement
has their hands on people's dna that are
in genealogy sites that's simply not
accurate but how do we address privacy
is that we
what we've done in california and what
we've advocated really across the world
is
follow a best practice develop what we
call an mou
a policy guideline so for instance when
we're using genealogy sites
we're not going to use a genealogy site
to solve a non-violent crime we're going
to use a genealogy
site like for instance in california
where we're only looking at violent
crimes
so it's a rape or it's a rape murder so
if you start to look at what's happened
since 2018 since the arrest of the
alleged golden state killer well over
100 cases have now been solved using
genealogy sites
um but they're all rate murders and so
we're we're trying to
follow the guidelines that were put
forth in california when we started
familial searching in 20
2009 which is to balance that privacy
against public safety utilize it when
we've really exhausted all other
potential
sources of investigation and and
really follow this best practice so
violent crimes
exhausted all leads and again we're not
sharing anybody's dna people that upload
their dna to a genealogy site
there's 26 million people that have done
that law enforcement has their hands
only on the bad guy's dna because he
left it behind
so education and following best
practices are really the keys
to overcoming any impediments when we
start talking about privacy
okay thank you anne-marie
now um let's take some some audience
questions
shall we um we have a couple of
questions here
um let me see this is a question for
anna
a local databases like orange county is
limited on the method
of dna analysis pcr versus
next generation sequencing or are they
able to utilize other technologies
anna so here in orange county
um we use just pcr so we uh our database
is composed of str profiles
um california law howard doesn't specify
what kind of
technology is used it just says that
law enforcement databases are allowed
for identification purposes
okay um to
a question for fred fred how did your
agency get the samples to develop a
local database
yeah so there's there's nothing in
pennsylvania law talking about the
databases so we we just start our local
database and we
um we collect dna on every crime scene
so that's how we get uh forensic samples
as far as reference samples
we ask everybody as i said we're
convicted felon states so there's
nothing that precludes me from
asking and getting consensual dna we
have about 95 percent of the people
that we ask give us their dna it's crazy
and people don't understand why someone
would give up their dna but they do i
have my theories on it
but they give us their dna we uh we read
them a uh
a a consent that was uh that was written
by our district attorney's office it
covers everything
he changes it every now and then uh adds
more things in there which i'm which i'm
all in favor of
uh we let the person swab their own
mouth we let them know that this is for
criminal investigations
so there's no there's no questioning
what we're doing with the dna
and again 95 percent of people give it
to us we have about
33 34 000 profiles
in our database and uh for us that
that's pretty darn good since we started
2010 with zero so um and we've got some
some great success so people give up
their dna
yeah so a general question
um is what is one of the most unusual
samples you've
been successful with getting dna from as
does anyone like
would anyone like to take that question
just an unusual what kind of unusual
samples have you
uh had where dna could could be obtained
from
i'll throw something out there jack just
this is way back
mid 90s was a dna off of the leaf
somebody i had a victim that was
kidnapped and raped in a in a driveway
of somebody's car
and there was a leaf on the ground and
the perpetrator left his uh semen
on the leaf so incredible work by the
crime lab
wow okay you win
yes yeah
okay um i think we can move on um
[Music]
to the next series of pre-chosen
questions
uh we will continue to take questions
from the audience
let's move on then to new technologies
uh integration of new technologies into
operations
the challenges and and strategies to
overcome new technologies
so some of the panelists currently use
rapidly dna technology um so
in in what ways has it been used in your
jurisdiction
um in and well we've heard that already
but basically how does how can other
jurisdictions
uh basically implement this technology
uh in in in their own in their own area
um fred so you know
as i said in the opening we have the the
instrument the rapid id
machine is in the police station uh and
it could be operated three o'clock in
the morning i have uh all my supervisors
and all my detectives
are trained in its use and are able to
utilize it so
the whole purpose of this great
technology is to get 90-minute dna
results and get someone off the street
and and hopefully get them arraigned at
three o'clock in the morning thereby
stopping
their uh their crime spree the other
thing that we use it for
also is exoneration and we haven't
talked about that
uh yet um you know a lot of folks will
come on and uh you know a lot of people
will be against what we're doing but
this is all this is all we this has
already been used by us to exonerate
people
we had a uh a sexual assault case that
was
iron clad case without dna uh
victim positively identified the guy the
guy had no alibi the guy was a career
uh sex offender all these things but to
make a long story short
uh you know we got his dna and he was
already incarcerated and
for this crime and we cleared him so we
got him out of jail immediately
um so rapid could be used for that and
also it used for
identification of bodies and we've done
that uh
we we did it on a case where four boys
two summers ago were
were killed in our county and uh three
were buried in one spot and one was
buried in another spot and
the three bodies were beyond recognition
and we were able to get
uh you know dna off their toothbrushes
and then dna
uh off of them and we were able to
identify them to give families closure
so not only for criminal investigations
but for uh you know exoneration
and for identification and the the the
uses of this technology
is endless
yes um anna do you want to add anything
that
that obviously threads from the law
enforcement side that you're from the
lab side
uh about implementing and the challenges
you face
or what what other agencies would face
in terms of implementing a rapid dna
program from the lab standpoint yeah so
um here uh we use the rapid hit 200
instrument and what we see with rapid
dna technology is that it's
great it's very fast we get our results
our instruments two hours
but is limited to high quantity dna
samples so we limit our submissions to
um blood cigarette butts uh buckle swabs
gum semen if it's not from a sexual
assault kit
and saliva and in addition to that we
make sure that there's always enough
sample that two samples can be processed
so
their priority is always for the crime
lab so our
crime lab gets a primary piece of
evidence so if it's a blood stain
they'll get the first swab and then the
second swab will be
submitted to rapid dna for our
investigated lead or for the
pointer and the reason being is that
that crime scene evidence that's
processed at the crime lab
will be the one that's used um for court
purposes
and we do this on a wide range of crime
types from serious and violent crimes
um to property crimes so um like fred's
program we are we operate 24 7
um depending on the um crime
um we will roll out in the middle of
night if necessary um
and we've seen great success so with our
rapid dna instrument
we get searchable results so a dna
profile that i can search against the
database
in over 75 of our cases and of those
cases
that we conduct a search we get a hit 40
of the time
so and when this happens when uh we get
a rapid dna hit our prosecutors and law
enforcement agencies know because it's a
rapid dna hit
to work quickly to get additional
evidence and to file the case
so if the evidence is probative the
rapid dna hit allows for probable cause
to obtain the search warrant or the
arrest warrant and in these cases we see
that the law enforcement agency so
it's open county-wide to over 30
agencies
they're able to collect this additional
evidence such as stolen property that
can help hold the case or fresh witness
or victim statements such as a six-pack
id lineup or even fresh suspect
statements where they're so shocked that
they have
been arrested so quickly that they even
provide a full confession um
so we see that our prosecutors are able
to file these cases
um 80 over 80 of the time
um and we have a 99 conviction rate for
these cases and the
the reason is 99 and not 100 is because
one case
unfortunately the defendant passed away
before um
uh the case was adjudicated so we've
seen great success with this and
comparing it to our codiships our lab
also or our office also uh files all of
our
uh reviews and files any codifieds that
are
made at the lab we see 40
of those cases being filed right away
and then a lot of them are stuck in
pending state where the law enforcement
agencies have to go out
get more information get more evidence
because when they get these hits from
the lab
months six months 10 months
even a year later you have a lot less
evidence there
and the dna is not as impactful as it is
when you get
um the dna results in two hours like we
do with rapid dna
okay thank you thank you anna um last
the last of the pre-chosen areas
would be prioritization of cases and
samples for dna analysis
um obviously we are victims of our own
success
in the dna business so to speak um
the the demand is greater than the
supply so to speak
um so the question is what are the
biggest bottlenecks in getting casework
completed
uh whether your police whether your
uh prosecutor lab person so
and marie do you have any comments about
what what you find
are the biggest bottlenecks in getting
the casework completed that you need for
your
for your work well i hate to say this
but i'm sure it's true for everybody's
it's all about resources and how much
money we're able to put into
uh the laboratory work i mean the
prioritization it's pretty simple and
pretty reasonable is we're going to
obviously identify the violent crimes
first
we're going to work our lab is going to
work those cases just like every other
lab is going to do but
but what we also know from statistics
and fred's really kind of mention this
is we know that
drug crimes and property crimes lead to
violent crimes and we've seen from
california doj's own studies
that if we can um identify those people
early on
um that that we will in fact prevent
crime because we know that people that
have committed violent crimes oftentimes
have a history of drug
and theft crimes so the more we can do
the more funding we can get
but ultimately the bottleneck really
just comes down to resources and having
the ability to do all those crimes
whether it's through grant funding from
the feds or the state governments
or whether it's just your local
governments dedicating those resources
but i don't ever want to underestimate
the power of the tool as fred mentioned
to exonerate people so we can never
forget that that this
you know people may not know that before
we actually arrest somebody on a rape
murder
20 people were already eliminated
because law enforcement collected
samples so
it is the greatest tool ever to identify
both the the guilty and exonerate the
innocent so
but resources are the ultimate need yeah
does anyone else like to take that that
question what's the one more one more
person what what is the biggest
bottlenecks in getting casework
completed
anna but you're a lab a lab person
so for our lab the biggest backlog is
with property crime cases we do
our county does um always collect uh on
property crime it was an initiative that
was um
started uh years ago but you know with
these property crimes it's high volume
with lots of samples that can be tested
in addition to
the crime state evidence you always have
elimination swabs um to test as well
so what our office implemented um years
ago is a process that we call triage and
that's guidelines to prioritize
certain property crime cases and the
evidence that will be tested
so with this process they limit
the number of crimes and samples to
three crimes and samples that will be
approved for testing
at the initial stages of course you can
always go back
and um test more so you always collect
and then just you know the three most
probatives most
the samples with the most um forensic
value and will be probated for the
prosecutors are chosen to be um
processed at first um so that they can
get through the cases quicker
um because not and we have a rapid dna
instrument but
not everything can be do done through
rapid a lot of these proper crimes
there's touch dna um vehicle burglaries
you can
swab the steering wheel you can swap the
gear shift so our lap still plays a huge
part in our
property crimes but you know as anne
marie said there's just not enough
resources there are not enough forensic
scientists there's not enough
you know just instrumentation at the lab
to be able to do this and without
further resources there's always going
to be that backlog no matter how much
you limit this
okay thank you anna um same old same old
so to speak with regard to resources
right
um uh anyway let's let's take some
some audience questions now um to all
the panelists
um how might you couch forensic dna
tools
in the recent grassroots call for police
reform
so uh with all you know basically how
does how does forensic dna tools how
does how do we couch these tools
uh with regard to the recent calls for
police reform
anyone want to take that one up first
stab at that uh dr valentine so i think
it's important i mean
you know yes there's been calls for
police reform but people need to
understand
and i've said it many times and i'll say
it again it is the
dna is the greatest tool to find the
truth no matter what that truth is
whether it's somebody's
uh guilty of a crime or whether
somebody's exonerative crime and there's
no better example at least from my
perspective
than in california with a with our
recent exoneration of an individual that
was in prison for 15 years in another
county
named ricky davis because it was through
dna
that he was ultimately exonerated and it
was ultimately through genetic genealogy
that
the actual killer who's now charged with
this particular crime so
when we talk about police reforms it to
me i look at it more as a justice system
question is how are we assuring the
public
that we are not only arresting but
prosecuting the right people
and and truly there's no better way to
do that than the use of forensic dna
and jack you know emery is exactly right
and i'm sure anna can weigh in as well
as far as
the laboratory side people are just
scared of it if we called dna
something else abc maybe people wouldn't
be afraid of it but they're so afraid of
dna they think that law enforcement is
getting
your darkest secrets of your family and
you know are you blue eyed or green eyed
or right-handed or you this or you're
that
it doesn't tell us anything but male or
female and it points
a person to a crime scene it's and it's
it's
it's unbelievably accurate people are so
scared of it if anything the dna
people should embrace it more but is
going to ensure
that the guilty people go to jail and
the innocent people are not incarcerated
dna helps do that and i think people are
just afraid of it because of television
because of tv shows that are
misrepresenting it
um because people don't understand it
because people think
uh of you know shows like jerry springer
we're not looking for who's you know you
are the father that's not what we're
doing out here
we're trying to put somebody to a crime
scene
and if you're not attached to that crime
scene if you're not the person that did
that
then you're not going to come up and
you're not going to hit and
it's unbelievable technology and i think
people are just
don't understand it i didn't understand
it until 2010 we got involved in it
if you told me i'd be talking about dna
now 10 years ago i would have told you
you were crazy that i had no interest in
it
but it is the latest and greatest and
and rapid just you know
ups the game it's just uh it's just
unbelievable
the amount of work that it can do and
the amount of crime
it can solve and prevent and i think we
can't forget that prevention
like anna said earlier it truly prevents
crime
and it's a it's a number that's not
measurable
thanks uh gian would you like to
contribute to this uh question
yes i would i think the thing that we
need to we need to remember is that
dna is science and in the procedure
markers for ethnicity so if we
using dna to its fullest potential is
the greatest hope that we have
to eliminate racial bias in our criminal
justice system
because either those numbers match or
they don't as ann marie said it's the
truth
and that's what we need we need the
truth to find
the true perpetrators of crime and to
exonerate the innocent
and to absolutely eliminate racial bias
in our criminal justice system
thank you anna are you are you okay or
would you like to contribute to that
question um i think the other presenters
uh
have spoken yeah okay um
the um a question for um
uh anna and maybe fred what type of
training
does the police agencies have prior to
using rapid dna
so and then yeah so for
uh in orange county we go to all of our
agencies and train them
on how to collect the evidence for rapid
dna
testing so we continually go out we have
a
training presentation that we do and
since there's always high turnover
new people being brought on to different
teams new detectives
we're continuously training and our
officers
at the outside agencies that are not
part of the da's office do not actually
test the evidence
on the instrument we have investigators
that are employed by the da's office
investigators and investigative
assistants
that are trained here in the office to
run the instrument
and those go they go through a more
rigorous training um process which is
analogous to crime lab training so
there's they observe it
um using people using the instrument
they do supervised um
training of the instrument there's a
mock samples competency test there's a
written competency test as required
readings
so they go through a very rigorous
training program before they're allowed
to
use the instrument and process these dna
samples
okay thank you um this is for
ann marie and or jayanne jian
in some countries the law prohibits
collecting samples for dna databases
from convicted offenders
because a person should not be forced to
produce evidence against
him or herself what's your view of that
this is this is um
do you have a and maria and marie or
gianna
well in the united states um you don't
have any kind of constitutional right
not to provide
physical evidence if your physical
evidence is not considered to be
a violation of the constitution so we
have in everything when gian talks about
the movement across this country to
collect samples not just from convicted
offenders but from
felony or sds there's a whole body of
law
that supports that collection of
evidence and
quite frankly as far as i'm concerned is
is when when we have
those types of individuals whether it's
arrestees or
convicted offenders we should be
collecting because
it again obviously identifies
individuals and eliminates others
jian do you have any any comment on on
that
i totally agree with anne marie uh i
believe that
that it is it's a just identification
uh that's all it is and that's you know
that's what the supreme court of the
united states has ruled so
okay um well i think i think we're we're
running out of time now we we haven't
got
gotten to all of the questions from the
audience
um so i think typically what would
happen is that
these questions will be um collated and
answers provided
after the uh after the meeting to
to the person asking the question so uh
we need to close the session now um i'd
like to thank
the uh before doing so of course
what we've heard is that um
rapid dna um is being used right now
in the criminal justice system within
the us and
with with some success and that is tied
into
the use of voluntary databases um
as opposed to the standard code type
databases and
the use of this is expected to increase
not only
by law enforcement but within the crime
lab itself
but in terms of dna databases we still
need to expand
the use of these databases expand the
number of offenders
the types of offences we haven't gone as
far we haven't even discussed the
potential for a universal database
we didn't get to that but
dna plays a major role it's it's
objective
uh it it doesn't only
help to convict the
true perpetrator but also to exonerate
the innocent
so we always have to be aware of that um
and education
is a very important part of trying to
persuade the body politic
um through you know through education
basically
to provide the necessary resources
because of course
as we've talked about already resources
are
a big big issue still so typically you
want faster better and cheaper
we've always gone with better we've now
gone to faster
faster is rapid etc but we also
you know we need to talk about the
cheaper aspect as well because with
becomes cheaper it's easier to sell to
the body politic
so um with that then i'd like to thank
the panelists for their their time and
expertise the organizers and support
staff
at firmware lab roots for putting on
this meeting both virtually
and across three different worldwide
time zones and of course to all of the
audience participants
without his presence we would literally
be speaking to an empty room
um i hope it has been of some value to
all
so uh and with that i have to say
goodbye and will now pass the baton to
the incomparable
shireen darwish thank you everyone
thank you
sharon you're on mute
sorry thank you dr valentine and thank
you to all our panelists
that was a great uh discussion and thank
you to the audience for all the great
questions
at this time we'll be taking a short
break to give you a chance to visit our
exhibits
posters and applications hall and the
hit of the year presentation will start
at 10 15 a.m pacific standard time